- It is in every nook
and cranny of academia.
A lot of people said exactly
what you were saying,
well this is just
some esoteric nonsense
that a few bozos
in the humanities
and the social sciences
are doing, absolutely not.
Right now most of
the granting agencies
that fund you know, research
in the natural sciences.
In physics and
chemistry and biology
and the neurosciences will
require the grant applicants
to submit a, what I call
a DIE religion statement.
DIE stands for diversity,
inclusion and equity
where you literally have
to state right up front,
irrespective of what
you're studying,
what is it that you've
done to you know,
promote DIE principles and
what are you going to do
if you were to win the grant
in promoting DIE principles.
(calm music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and
this is The Rubin Report.
Quick reminder everyone to
subscribe to our YouTube channel
and then resubscribe when
the subscribe gremlins
unsubscribe you.
And joining us today
is an evolutionary
behavioral scientist,
a Professor of Marketing
at Concordia University
and author of the new
book, "The Parasitic Mind:
"How Infectious Ideas Are
Killing Common Sense".
Gad Saad, welcome back
to The Rubin Report.
- Oh my God, it's so
good to see you again.
I wish were being done
in person in California
but second best.
- I wish we were
doing this in person.
I know that you have a
love of Southern California
and the sun that is almost
unrivaled by other human beings.
One time we had you in
here after you had been
in SoCal for a few
weeks, your glow,
the color that you can
achieve, the bronze.
It almost blew out
our whole system,
but you have a very
nice tan right now.
- Well thank you, thank you.
Not bad for up in Canada.
So before we do anything,
I had to count beforehand
and we were trying
to figure it out.
This is either your seventh
or eighth appearance
on The Rubin Report.
You are now the most returning
guest of The Rubin Report.
Would you say
basically in terms of,
you've got a pretty
impressive CV.
Your resume is looking
pretty good but,
where does that fall in
the scheme of things?
- I think, if I only
put that on my CV
I've already made it, so.
You're top.
- All right, so look.
I wanna obviously dive
into the book and you know,
you guys sent us the
book a couple weeks ago
and when I was reading
it, I kept thinking
that what you're
explaining in this book
is what about 20 of us
have been yelling about
for the last five
years and a whole bunch
of mainstream media
people kept saying
oh this is just a college
campus thing, this ain't real.
You're all overstating
it, you're overblowing it
and now it's everywhere.
And some of these people
have actually had mea culpas.
We're seeing some people
who used to mock us
kind of go, oh maybe, maybe
they were kind of right
about some of this stuff.
So let's try it this way
for the first question.
Oh and I can see you're
putting your glasses on
so you're ready to be
a learned professor.
When did the ideas, when
did you first notice
that these bad ideas were
creeping into society
and then we'll sort of talk
about what the ideas are.
- Sure.
So I called them of
course in the book,
idea pathogens and
drawing a corollary
to how animals could
be parasitized by
actual brain worms.
I argue that human
beings can be parasitized
by another class of
pathogens, idea pathogens.
So and hence this is why it's
called The Parasitic Mind.
So I first noticed it
when I was a doctoral
student at Cornell.
I was taking a,
a course with my eventual
doctoral supervisor
J. Edward Russo who
is a mathematical
and cognitive psychologist.
And in the course he
assigned to his students
some postmodernist reading.
That was absolutely insane.
Now this was
published in the top,
the most prestigious
journal in the field,
Journal of Consumer Research.
You know very high impact factor
amongst the social sciences
and it was complete insanity.
It was basically what is often
referred to as a you know,
auto, you know the
guy was talking about
his consumatory experience
when he gets a warm erection
thinking about his wife.
And I'm thinking
this is science?
Well of course it's science
be according to these guys,
postmodernism is my truth.
So if I share it
with you, my truth
in a dear diary sense
it is just as valid
as quote, the scientific method.
And so when I was first
exposed to this postmodernism
I thought it was
absolute insanity.
Once I became a professor
I got my PhD in 1994,
became a professor,
I started seeing
this postmodernist thinking
throughout the halls of academia
and it was usually coupled
with a rejection of biology.
So biology is great in
explaining the behavior
of every single species
except human beings.
So this was the first instance
about 28, 30 years ago
when I first faced the insanity.
- So one of the things
I find interesting
and why I think you're
such a good communicator
about this stuff is a
lot of people think,
oh these, these bad ideas
and identity politics
and all of this
stuff, well this,
it only is on the arts
and it's only in you know,
the sort of
superfluous you know,
classes and things like that.
But because you come from
a science background,
you've seen these
things infect virtually
every level of academia right?
- It is in every nook
and cranny of academia.
A lot of people said exactly
what you were saying.
Well this is just
some esoteric nonsense
that a few bozos
in the humanities
and the social sciences
are doing, absolutely not.
Right now most of
the granting agencies
that fund you know, research
in the natural sciences.
In physics and
chemistry and biology
and the neurosciences will
require the grant applicants
to submit a, what I call
a DIE religion statement.
DIE stands for diversity,
inclusion and equity
where you literally have
to state right up front,
irrespective of
what you're studying
what is it that you've
done to you know,
promote DIE principles and
what are you going to do
if you were to win the grant
in promoting DIE principles.
Now a colleague of mine at
a fellow university here,
a sister university in Montreal,
a very prestigious university.
One of my alma maters,
is a physical chemist.
His grant application,
he's a very,
very accomplished
physical chemist.
His grant application was
stopped at the DIE statement
because they felt that it
wasn't sufficiently adhering
to the DIE tenets.
So those who think that
is just some esoteric
anomalous thing are
absolutely wrong.
- Can you go further with that
'cause I think a lot
of people hear that
and they're like oh but
the statement means well
and if that helps more black
or trans or whatever people
get into these fields,
that is somehow good.
But can you explain why that
is actually antithetical
to the type of research.
- Sure.
- That people like
you are trying to do.
- Look the scientific
method liberates us
from the shackles
of our identity.
That's what makes it
so wonderful right?
Listening to
transcendental experience
because I don't listen
to Barry White thinking
that I have a certain quota
of black singers that
I need to listen to.
He transcends whether
he's black or white.
He gives me goosebumps
because he's very white.
So art, literature, music,
the scientific method
are the laudable
endeavors that they are
precisely because they remove
those shackles of identity.
I come from a world
of identity politics
as we've discussed
on the show before
when I escaped Lebanon.
So the fundamental principle
on which classical liberalism
as you well know and
many of your viewers know
is a commitment to
individual dignity.
When you now say no,
your individual dignity
must be tied to some
tribal identity,
I don't care how accomplished
you are as a physicist.
Are you a transgender
person of color
and if yes we give
you the grant or no?
What could be a greater
cancer to individual dignity?
It's grotesque.
- Have you seen how it
sort of works its way up
in institutions in terms of
actually destroying the work?
So it's not, okay so you hire
you know, some of these people
not based purely on skill.
So you know, people
can understand that.
Okay so now you have a less
qualified group of people
at the bottom but
have you seen it
sort of really go up
the chain of command
until it's really just
wiped out everything?
- Absolutely, so in
the book I talk about
one effort right now in
Canadian universities
which refers to what's
called indigenization
of the university.
So the indigenization of the
university has many levels.
So on one level you have to
hire more indigenous people.
So that's kind of what
we've been talking about.
But this indigenization reflex
goes much, much further.
There is a professor at the
University of British Columbia
who was denied tenure
because she hadn't published
a sufficient number of
papers to get tenure.
She filed a complaint with
the Human Rights Tribunal
of British Columbia arguing
that she is an indigenous woman.
That in her culture,
the oral tradition
supersedes the written word.
Therefore by forcing me
to have to publish things
in tenure, that is violating
my you know, my culture.
So that's, so imagine
how insane that is.
But there's even a
more pernicious effect
of this indigenization.
This is, this goes to
the root of epistemology,
philosophy of knowledge.
The scientific method
is the only game in town
when we're trying to adjudicate
whether a hypothesis
is correct or not.
There is no indigenous
way of knowing.
There is no Lebanese
Jewish way of knowing.
There is no gay way of knowing.
There is the scientific method.
So once we start, we
start saying well,
if we wanna study
the environment,
we can't only rely on
the scientific method.
We need to go to
this tribe and learn
from their ancestral boogabooga,
you are violating essential
tenet of the scientific method
and it is grotesque.
- So, okay so that
gets us to why I love
the title of the book
because the word parasite.
That this in effect this awful
thing has attached itself
to all of us.
No matter how clear
thinking you are on this.
This is effecting your
life in a negative way
as much as it's effecting
someone who believes in it,
in what I assume they
think is a positive way.
Why the title, why
the word parasite?
- So as an evolutionary
psychologist
I often look to other
animals to draw comparisons
when I'm making some statement
about human cognition.
That field is called
comparative psychology.
Comparative in the sense that
you are comparing
across species.
So that's one of the tools that
evolutionary scientists use
when they are studying the
evolution of the human mind.
So as someone who has
looked at other animals,
I noticed that there was
this incredible field
called neuroparasitology whereby
these parasitologists study
how parasites can
enter the host's body
but instead of going for
example to your intestine,
the tapeworm goes
to your intestine.
Neuroparasites seek to infect
and alter the circuitry
of a host's actual brain.
So the classic example
would be toxoplasma gondii.
This is the one that many
of your viewers might know.
It can effect humans by,
the classic example
is with mice.
So a mouse that is infected
with toxoplasma gondii
loses its innate fear of cats
and it actually becomes
sexually attracted
to the cat's urine.
Not a very good sexual
attraction to have
if you're a mouse
because that helps the
parasite to complete
its reproductive cycle.
There's another type of
parasite that attacks the brains
of ungulates.
Moose, elk, deer and
when they are infected
with this parasite they start
engaging in circling behavior.
They start going
around in circle
unable to extricate themselves
from this motor pattern.
So even if the predators
are coming, they won't flee
and so I took these ideas
and I said well you know,
in a sense that's what's
happening to many people
who are parasitized
by these bad ideas.
Instead of going around in
circle like the helpless,
the hapless moose.
It leads us to the abyss
of infinite lunacy.
I'll just give you one
other quick example.
There is something
called the spider wasp.
The spider wasp will parasitize
spiders by stinging them.
It then takes this much
larger spider into its burrow.
It lays an egg and then
as the egg hatches,
it eats the spider in vivo.
Basically the spider
is alive but zombified.
Well I argue that, I argue
that political correctness
is exactly kind to the
spider wasp's sting.
It keeps us lulled
and it leads us
to the abyss of lunacy.
- So in a weird way
do you admire it?
Do you admire the genius
behind it at a certain level,
not the ideas specifically
obviously but it sort of,
when you were talking about that
what was ringing in my
head was the movie Alien
and there is this scene
where one you know,
and you can think of the
alien as the parasite right?
But you know the, one
of the scientists,
they really admire
the beauty of it,
the ingeniousness of it.
How it gets into the
body to then reproduce,
all of these things.
Do you sort of admire,
whoever sort of really
put these ideas together
to send them out
into the universe,
there's a certain beauty
as horrific as it is right?
- Well I'm glad you
mentioned Aliens
because it literally is a
manifestation of invaders
of the body snatchers.
In this case,
of the mind snatchers.
- Yeah.
- Right, that's exactly
what it is doing.
And if you read the
neuroparasitology literature,
it really reads
like science fiction
because there's this
incredible evolutionary dance
between the host
and the parasite
where the parasite is
trying to always find
ever clever ways as you
said, admirable ways
to dupe the host into its
own reproductive pursuits.
So in that nefarious
diabolic sense,
yes I admire these
incredible mind viruses.
- So do you think that
the host in this case,
just the average
social justice warrior
walking down the street
or the average person
who gets infected, you
know, through fake news,
bad news, whatever it might be.
The part that they're
getting from this
is somehow like, is it an ego
stroking that they're getting
or is it a I understand
the way the world really is
and nobody else.
Like what, what is it that
the host is actually getting?
Like is it a, it seems to be
a replacement for religion
or belief or
something like that.
- I mean I think it's a
combination of those factors.
One of the things that
I talk about in the book
is that all of these
various idea pathogens
share a couple of
things in common.
One is they are ways by
which we can free ourselves
from the shackles of reality.
I mean literally soar right?
So militant feminism frees us
from the shackles of biology.
Postmodernism frees
us from the shackles
of universal truths.
Trans activism, you
put trans on anything
as a prefix and it frees
you from your genitalia,
it frees you from your race.
I just need to put trans
and that's it right?
So for example I
trans-self identify
that yesterday I
fasted on Yom Kippur.
I didn't but I self
identified as having done so.
Therefore I was a trans Yom
Kippur faster, you get it?
So all of these
different idea pathogens
liberate us from the
shackles of reality
but they also do something else.
They all start
from a noble place
and I mean noble not
in the satirical way
I often use on social media.
I literally mean it, they start
off with a good intention.
So for example
if you look at all of the
social constructivists.
Social constructivists are
those that reject biology
as being relevant in
explaining human affairs.
Everything is due to
a social construction.
Well that penchant
began as a noble desire
to free the human
condition from biology
because all sorts of
really nefarious evil folks
had misused Darwinian
theory right?
The Nazis said hey,
it's a natural struggle
between the races,
the Jews lost, we're the Aryans.
Hey that's Darwinian,
what's wrong with killing
the Jews right?
Eugenicists say the same thing.
Hey if you are gay,
we sterilize you
so that you don't reproduce,
we get your genes
out of the pool.
He it's Darwinian,
well of course
it's got nothing to do
with Darwinian theory.
But the ones who
were promulgating
these idea pathogens
were coming from a noble place.
If we create a new reality,
hopefully we can forestall
these bad things.
So they start off
with noble causes,
freeing us from the
shackles of reality
but then of course, when
you murder the truth
there's always
downstream consequences
that are nefarious and that's
what we're seeing today.
- I can't do one
show without saying
the road to hell is paved
with good intentions.
That's what it always
seems to boil down to
one way or another.
So do you think
that for those of us
that were on YouTube and
podcasts and everything else
and the whole you know,
intellectual dark web phenomenon
and that whole thing that
largely has sort of disappeared.
Oddly when we sort
of need it most.
Do you think in a way?
I wanna word this correctly.
Do you think we failed in a way
that because we were talking
about all of this stuff,
a bunch of us were.
Jordan Peterson
obviously and Ben Shapiro
and the Weinstein brothers and
a whole slew of other people.
It's not that we weren't
discussing these things
and Sam Harris of course.
But it still all happened.
It still all here we are.
Do you think we
missed something?
Was there something else
that we could've done
that would've been a better
defense against the pathogen?
No because I think that to
eradicate these pathogens
it's a longterm game.
It took 40, 50 years
of brainwashing,
of parasitic
infestation in academia.
I always say by the way,
it takes intellectuals
to come up
with the truly dumbest ideas.
This is why all
these idea pathogens
start within the
university ecosystem.
So it took 40, 50 years
before we ended up
with Justin Trudeau
as Prime Minister
who basically embodies
all of the idea pathogens
that I discuss in the book.
So the fact that the IDW came
up was certainly a good thing.
Because you had some
people with large platforms
who were calling
you know, alarm,
you know ringing the alarm bell
but it really does
require the involvement
of every single individual
to truly win this battle.
So when I tell people, you
know I get millions of emails
and so do you
where someone says,
well I don't have your platform,
I'm not the fancy professor,
I'm not Dave Rubin,
I'm not Joe Rogan,
what can I do?
Well you can do a lot.
When someone, when
your professor says
something in class
that you find is objectionable,
challenge them politely.
If someone says
something on Facebook
that you disagree with,
challenge them politely.
In other words it's
trench warfare.
It's not just Rubin and
Jordan Peterson and Gad Saad
who are holding the
mantle of you know,
killing these idea pathogens.
Everybody who has a
stake in this battle
which is everybody who
wants to commitment
to reason, logic,
science and common sense
should be engaged in the battle.
The problem is most people,
because of cowardice,
because they diffuse
responsibility on others
don't get engaged and
therefore the idea pathogens
keep eating away at us.
- Well that would sort of
make you admire the pathogen
in a double fashion wouldn't it?
Because it's using their own
fear against them at the,
it's using their,
their nobility,
they think they're
doing something good
at some level when you know,
and then it's also using
fear to keep them quiet
once they wake up to
it, pretty clever.
- Exactly, no it's
beautiful right?
I mean that's why
propagandists are so desired
because they know how to
construct the machinery
of the meme so that it can
have maximal impact right?
So they are virologists
of the human mind.
One of my endorsers by the
way in the book is Paul Offit.
The reason why I chose him, I
mean first he's a great guy.
He's a virologist,
he's a pediatrician
who's developed some vaccines
for child you know, viruses.
The reason why I wanted him to.
Because in the same way that
he combats actual viruses
that go around your body,
I'm combating viruses
of the human mind.
So we're both parasitologists,
just dealing with
different organs
and different
types of pathogens.
- Yeah, do you think
there's a limit?
We got into this
a little bit when,
when you interviewed me on
your show about my book.
Do you think there's a
limit to how the human mind
can fight this?
So one of the things that
I've sort of come around to
is that the people that rely
purely on the enlightenment,
that just logic and reason
in and of itself are enough
to coordinate a
society that can fight
all these horrible ideas, I
just don't believe it anymore.
I think that's why
we've seen these ideas
just infect everything.
Do you think that logic
and reason in and of itself
are enough?
Because I think we've
sort of watched a lot of,
a lot of our crew let's say,
sort of become
irrelevant in this fight
because relying on logic and
reason sometimes isn't enough.
- Yeah so in chapter
two of my book,
it's, the book is about
thinking versus feeling right?
Truth versus hurt feelings
and the reason why I
set up that dichotomy
is precisely to
address in a sense,
some of your points which is,
it's not so much that
these two systems
should be pitted
against each other.
It's not that we are a thinking
animal or a feeling animal.
It's that depending
on the condition,
we should trigger
the right system.
So when I'm walking
down an alley
to take a shortcut to get home
and I see four young
men loitering around,
my heart will start pounding,
I'll start getting nervous.
I'm getting a evolved
fear-based response
that makes perfect sense.
In this case, my affective
system has kicked in
and it makes sense
that it would do so.
On the other hand,
my affective system
will not help me get an A
plus on my calculus exam.
I need to trigger in this case,
my cognitive system right?
My higher order cognition
and so you're exactly right.
You can't always, when you're
trying to change hearts
and minds only use
reason and logic
although in chapter
seven of the book
I do talk about how
we can construct
normalogical networks to
try to convince people
of our position which
we can talk about.
But I also use satire, I
use sarcasm as you know.
That's really getting to your
emotional basis there right?
So really you have to be someone
who's got a whole toolbox
of persuasion strategies
and you pull out
the right tool depending
on the context.
So it's not reason or
emotions, use the right one
in the right context.
- Right so with
that in mind though,
does it surprise you that
your allies these days
would line up more on the right
even though I know
you consider yourself
an old school liberal and
that was sort of, your home.
You know I know a little
something about that.
Like are you surprised
or do you think
that this was just
the natural extension
of where this was all gonna go?
- Well it's, it more
than surprises me,
it makes me indignant.
Because the word liberal
has been usurped.
The word progressive
It's again it's a
propagandist's game right?
So by the way, most people
are such cognitive misers
that if you ask them
why are you voting
for the Liberal Party,
let's say Justin Trudeau.
They, it will literally
end at the fact
well I'm liberal,
that's the Liberal Party,
I'm not conservative.
I mean it's literally
that, it's fast
and frugal right?
- Yeah.
- I'm, you know the
Democrats seem progressive,
the conservatives seem like
mean and old fashioned.
That's the level of cognition
that people attribute
to these types of decisions.
So in that sense, I'm
not surprised that
I'm now tied to the conservative
values because they're,
that's really where the home
of true freedom lies today.
So I don't care to be in,
I'm in the tribe of truth,
I don't have a home.
- Yeah but do you see a moment.
I mean I guess this is what I'm,
'cause I'm still trying to
parse this out for myself.
Do you see a moment or a
weakness in liberalism.
So I think what you're
saying is you see
the weakness as too
much of a reliance on
only one piece of
the toolkit right?
Like you're saying it's
just too much based in logic
and reason and
that their toolkit,
whether it's about belief
or satire or something else.
They needed some other
tool, something like that?
- Sure I mean I think you
probably have seen this
that when they talk
about you know who does,
which of the two parties is
better at creating memes,
viral memes.
I mean in a, right?
Who is better at comedy right?
I have a section in the book
where I talk about all
sorts of professors.
Incredibly you know,
prominent professors
who were all canceled
because of a misplaced joke.
I mean having a Nobel
Prize does not protect you
from the ire of the
angry humorless ones.
Right, then I
referred to a book,
well originally a
book but then a movie.
The Name of the Rose, if you
remember The Name of the,
did you see it Dave by the way?
- I didn't see it, no.
- Well it's an amazing
movie that takes place
I think in the 11th
or 12th Century.
Staring Sean Connery and
a young Christian Slater
where a whole bunch
of monks are dying
and it turns out
that they're dying.
I don't wanna give it away in
case anybody wants to see it,
because one monk is
trying to stop them
from reading a book that
has satire and comedy.
So satire and comedy
is exactly forbidden,
whenever a dictator
comes to town
because it is so
incredibly powerful
to try to show the
holes in a particular,
in a particular ideology.
That's why I use it.
By the way some of
our common friends
who are highfalutin and so
highbrow in the ivory towers,
they're actually fraudulent
because by not using
all of the tools that
are at your disposal
to try to shape
hearts and minds,
you're losing an opportunity.
So I never consider
myself above the use
of all sorts of tools.
So for example you've
seen me use the,
I don't know if you've seen
my hiding under
the table routine.
Where.
- Yeah, yeah yeah.
- What am I doing there?
I am mocking the, now
this hysteria by the way
is not something
that I'm making up.
You could go to my personal page
where these incredibly
accomplished female professors
are literally saying
to one another,
that they are now going to
be afraid to go to campus
because this new justice
might come into you know,
might be nominated and confirmed
and therefore it will be
too dangerous for them.
I mean do you
genuinely believe that?
I mean are you this idiotic?
So it's frustrating.
- Yeah.
- That's why I'm
often so indignant.
- I think you probably
saw a little bit of it
but I know most of my
audience has seen it.
When I did a talk at
University of New Hampshire
and they're screaming
at me and heckling me
and the whole thing
and pulling fire alarm
and this woman or a girl,
student starts screaming
"We could be killed when
we walk out of here."
And I said to her, I was like,
what are you talking about?
I mean it's New Hampshire, we're
in New Hampshire at 5 p.m..
As if people are just being
mowed down on the streets
but what I realized was
the way she yelled it to me
shows how the parasite, to
bring it to this conversation
had overridden all of
her logic and reason
and certainly humor was
really off the table
and what was left was just
sort of this screaming lunacy.
So that, does that also show
you the emotional state?
Like it's all tied into
their emotional state too.
- Exactly, the one who
is most hysterical wins.
Just like I have a
section in the book
where I talk about the
one who has the highest
victimology score wins.
Now many people that have
probably come on your show
have talked about you know,
the victimology currency
and what I call
victimology poker
but I may or may
not have discussed
on a prior show when I
came on your platform,
I offer the actual
psychiatric explanation
for why this
victimology currency
has become the most
important metric
by which we adjudicate
debates right?
It's no longer about
here is my argument,
please give me yours
and let's see who wins
in the battle of ideas.
It's who screams louder,
who's more hysterical,
who's the bigger victim?
And I argue, so 10
years ago in 2010
I had written a scientific paper
published in a medical journal
where I was talking about
Munchausen syndrome by proxy
and Munchausen syndrome
is where someone feigns
a medical condition so that
they can garner sympathy
and empathy.
Munchausen syndrome by proxy
is when you take someone
who's under your care,
your biological child,
your pet, your elderly parent,
you harm them willfully
so that you can then
garner the empathy
and sympathy by proxy.
So I argued that the
hysteria that we see today,
the Jussie Smollett who
is no longer satisfied
with making a million
dollars per episode,
he needs to be the
biggest victim.
If he doesn't have a
victimology narrative,
he hasn't succeeded.
Well the mechanism by
which this initiates itself
is through what I call
collective Munchausen
and collective
Munchausen by proxy.
- How do you think Trump
possibly understood this?
It seems very obvious to
me that he understand,
you know he may not understand
every scientific principle
you're laying out there
or the research
behind it or something
but just that he
intuitively understands
and if, if he was
watching this would say,
oh yeah that's the stuff
I'm fighting against.
- I think it's, so one of
the things that I teach
my students, whether
it be the undergraduate
and BA, PhD and I'm
trying to explain to them
the biological roots
of consumer behavior.
I say look, ultimately
a good marketer
is one who understands
human nature
and exactly what you said.
They may not have
taken my courses
or read my books to know
the scientific mechanisms
behind the principles but
they know if this product X
will work or not as
a function of whether
it is congruent with
human nature or not.
So what Trump has is
a good understanding,
he's an evolutionary
psychologist.
He may be a crass
evolutionary psychologist,
he may be a vulgar one,
he may not use the
right vernacular,
he may not have a big lexicon
but he certainly
understands human nature
and that allows him to
win in these exchanges
in ways that the
other idiots don't.
Do you think there is a,
a way that they all
sort of need him?
One of the things I've
been thinking about lately
is how if you take the real
never Trump conservatives,
the people who he's
doing the stuff
that they always wanted done,
the conservative stuff,
he's doing it but yeah,
they don't like his
affect and all that.
And then you take the you know,
sort of the disaffected
lefties who can't support him
even if he's saving the
Republic in some odd way
because they you know, they
wanna go to nice parties.
That they both need Trump.
Do you think that
there is like actually,
a reasoning behind that.
Like they need to
point to somebody else
to sort of inflate
their own value?
- Well yes, I mean I think,
I do remember on a previous
show I talked about
Trump representing an
aesthetic injury right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- So I walk around the world,
you know, highfalutin
language and sipping
and looking at those
great unwashed people
and therefore I
expect those around me
to speak with that
you know, affectation.
To speak with that
vernacular and so on
and then here comes this
brash, is he from Queens,
where's he from, Queens right?
- Yeah, yeah yeah.
- So he's from Queens,
he's vulgar, he's
brash, he's a guy,
you know yes he's
wealthy but he seems like
he's got an eighth grade,
eighth level you know vocabulary
and he repudiates all the
things that stoke my ego.
I'm speaking now
as let's say the,
the highfalutin lefty right?
How could this guy ascend
to the highest office
when I've made a career
out of repudiating
all that he stands for?
If he's successful,
I am a fraud.
Therefore I have to put him
up on top of this mountain
and constantly enunciate
how much he disgusts me,
how much he is an
existential threat.
I mean the people who have said
that he is an existential
threat for four years,
every day they
reset the counter.
Today is when the
earth will end.
Then it's like the
doomsday cults right?
What do they say?
That on July 7th is when
the day end, the world ends.
When it doesn't end that
day, they change the date.
That's what the existential.
- They forgot to carry the one,
that's what usually happens.
- Exactly.
- It's so interesting because
as I see this all unfold
and then I do now,
it's a weird thing,
it feels like sci-fi to
me but I see Trump as
sort of a bulwark against it.
I also see sort of that
they wouldn't, it's almost
as if they wouldn't know
how to define themselves.
I think that's what
you're getting to.
That if they didn't
have that thing,
but yet at the same time
to me that's like you know,
the barbarians are at the gate,
they're about to
push the gate down,
there's one guy
guarding the door
and you're mocking that guy.
Doesn't end well
for you probably.
- Exactly.
Was it Douglas Murray, I
haven't read his book yet
but I think he's the one
who said something like,
you know as the folks
are coming to take over,
you're worried about their
gender pronouns or whatever.
- Well he said as the
barbarians are at the gate
we'll be debating what
gender pronouns they use.
- Exactly, sorry I just
closed the printer.
So that's exactly
it and so look,
I think on a previous show
you and I had discussed
what are some of the
reasons why these,
why a whole bunch of, you
know 63 million people
voted for him right?
And one of the reasons
I gave at the time
which is worth repeating
is that people,
Trump might fail if
you put a whole bunch
of attributes together.
In other words his whole package
might be inferior to
someone else or not,
we can debate that.
But if you use for example
a lexicographic rule.
Lexicographic rule
basically says
I look at my most
important attribute
and I choose the one
that scores the best
of that most
important attribute.
Well if I use that
decision rule,
there is an endless
number of ways
by which I can choose Trump.
If I care about authenticity,
well whether you like
his authenticity or not,
he's more authentic
than other candidates,
therefore he would win.
If you don't like open borders
and that's the only attribute
you care about, he would win.
So there is an endless
number of perfectly rational
decision rules
that I could apply
and it could come out perfectly
rationally for Trump to win.
What upsets me about some
of our common friends
is that they're not willing
to entertain that conversation
which by the way speaks to
an important thing in my book
which is the fact that you
are educated and intelligent
doesn't serve as an inoculation
against you being
parasitized by idea pathogens
because many of our
common friends have PhDs
and they're accomplished and
they've written great books
and guess what, they're some
of the biggest sufferers
of ostrich parasitic syndrome.
- Yeah and that's not to
throw anyone under the bus.
I mean this is purely just to,
I think continue to
try to wake people up
to some of this stuff.
- Exactly, look.
Some of our common
friends with whom I have.
By the way, yesterday
I put up a thing
where I was defending
Richard Dawkins
for having been deplatformed
at Trinity College Dublin and
a whole bunch of people were.
- Yeah, crazy.
- Yeah, it's crazy.
People were sending me
angry emails saying,
well why are you defending him?
You know how he was
going crazy about Trump
or how he's going
crazy about Brexit?
The fact that I defend him
because of a universal principle
doesn't imply that
I have to agree
or disagree with him
on every other issue
and the fact that I have to
enunciate this clearly to you
shows you how parasitized
most people are.
- 20 years ago when you were
first teaching about this stuff
and even before that
when you were in school
learning about all this.
Did you ever think
that this would,
that you were gonna be
talking about politics?
Because you spend a lot of time,
you know it's not that
you're talking about politics
all the time but
everything is now political
and you talk about
politics on Twitter
and when I bring you on
or you go on other shows,
people ask you your
thoughts on politics.
Are you, or does that seem like
it was gonna be the
obvious end of all of this
that because of
the way it spreads
that it would end up there?
- No, I don't, I would
be lying if I said
I had the foresight of where
my engagement was gonna go.
What was clear from my training
is I was studying psychology
of decision making.
So one of the things
when you study psychology
of decision making, one
of the things you do is
you study what's
called rational choice.
So for example if I
prefer car A to car B
and I prefer car B to car C,
it has to be that I
prefer car A to car C.
That's called the
transitivity axiom.
If I violate this
order of preference,
then I am being
quote, irrational.
So part of my training
in my doctoral studies
was to study psychology
of decision making
or behavioral decision theory
which by the way
led to a Nobel Prize
to one of my
professors at Cornell,
Richard Thaler and so I
come from a group of folks,
several of whom who
have won the Nobel Prize
for demonstrating that
economic decision making
is sometimes faulty.
So it was already
part of my training
to study irrational behavior.
But what was a surprise to
me was that the irrationality
would seep its way from
this very circumscript,
you know mathematical axiom to
politics, to popular culture.
So in a sense, I was trained
to look at human irrationality.
I just didn't know
that I would go into
all of these different fields.
- Yeah have you been, we've
talked about this a little bit.
But since I haven't had
you on for probably,
maybe it's eight or 10 months
or something around that.
- [Gad] Maybe a bit
longer but yeah.
- Maybe even longer.
Can you just talk a little
bit about what it's like,
you're sort of in the
world of academia right now
and just dealing
with other professors
and have you been
ostracized by other people?
- Yes.
- And other kind of headaches
because I think humanizing
some of that stuff,
you know, you're not just some
spinning neuron out there.
You're a human,
you've got a family
and people you work
with and the rest of it.
It's not that this has no cost.
- Some might say a very
good looking human but yes.
- A gorgeous, bronze man.
- So I'll answer
this in several ways.
So one of the things that
people often tell me.
Well you know, you're
protected by tenure professor
so it doesn't take
such courage Dr. Saad.
Well, in 2017 I had to,
whenever I would go to
teach courses on campus
I had to be accompanied
by security who would then
lock the door of my class so
that if people left the room
they'd have to knock
to be let back in
because of the number of
death threats I was getting.
When I would leave
campus, when my wife
would come to pick me up.
I would literally have
something akin to kind of
a deflation from
an anxiety attack
because I didn't know when
they were gonna come at me.
Are the three guys that are
in the elevator with me,
are they the ones who
are gonna decapitate me?
So tenure doesn't
protect you from that.
Tenure doesn't protect you
from all of the opportunities
I would've had as an academic.
Other job offers, higher salary.
I've done denied now
several years in a row,
a chaired professorship
which I had held for 10 years
and it would be a cinch
for me to get it renewed
but because now how outspoken
I am and as known as I am now
a lot of people who would
be sitting on the committees
to decide was to give me the
chaired professorship or not
are not very happy with
my supposed big mouth
and irreverent
attitude and therefore
I don't get that
chaired professorship.
That chaired professorship comes
with a lot of money.
- Do you think?
- Go ahead.
- But do you think it's
because, do you think it's
because they are so infected
that they're against the
ideas or that they perhaps
subtly agree with you.
I suspect some of the
people in your department
probably agree with you
but don't wanna publicly,
you know if they're the one
that vote on you getting in,
well now they're screwed.
So and that goes.
- Yeah exactly.
- To the cowardice thing that
we were talking about earlier.
I get that a lot,
you're absolutely right
that the silent majority, I
think even within academia
is not on board with this lunacy
but again the fact that
they are a minority
doesn't suggest that their
diabolical destruction
is not something to
worry about right?
I always tell people, how many,
how many committed zealots
did it take to bring
down the Twin Towers?
Was it 190,000 people, no
it took 19 people right?
So I don't need 9000 blue-haired
social justice warriors
on campus to keep the
rest of us be quiet.
I just need a few of them
that are a lot more vociferous
and committed than
the rest of us
and then they will
cow us into silence.
So I think many professors
are exactly what you said.
They write to me, thank you so
much, you're keeping me sane.
I don't know how you have
the courage to do this.
I would have left academia
were it not because of you
and then they will often write,
so what do you suggest
I do because I'm afraid
and then I always tell
them the same thing.
It sounds harsh but it really
is, it cuts to the truth.
The 18-year-old guys
who landed on Normandy
were not granted safe passage.
They knew that 60, 70% of them
would be mowed down
like little mosquitoes
and yet they did it so that
Dave Rubin and Gad Saad
could sit here and
speak freely today.
So whatever it is that
you are afraid of,
it is a lot less than the
guys who landed on Normandy.
So stop being a
coward and speak out.
- It's so interesting
because you know,
I don't come from the
world of academia.
So I think one of the
things that has harmed
some of our friends' ability
to talk about this stuff is
they still wanna be
liked in those circles.
You come from those circles
and you've paid a price.
I don't come from those circles,
so that cost is very low for me
but what I find is I'm very
frustrated by the people.
Right now it's like look,
Trump is getting
critical race theory
out of the federal government.
That is incredible.
Right that's what,
what everybody,
what we've all been talking
about, identity politics.
It's like he's getting it
out of the federal government
and the contractors
the feds can work with.
He got rid of Title IX,
that mean we're you know,
in effect there was no
due process anymore.
I thought liberals
were for due process.
But it's like, they can't
give him that credit
so my frustration
these days is so aimed
at what was my side
that it's, it's,
it's not a comfortable
spot to be in actually.
- Well because their,
their tribalism supersedes
their desire to be truthful.
So there's a tension
that I discuss
in The Parasitic Mind between
two types of ethical systems.
There's deontological ethics.
Deontological ethics
is absolute truth.
It is never okay to lie,
that would be a
deontological statement.
A consequentialist ethical
position would be if your wife
or husband asks you do I
look fat in those jeans,
you might lie to
protect their ego.
Therefore it is consequentialist
okay to lie in this case
because it's a better cause.
Well a lot of.
- You might just wanna
get laid that night Gad, as
long as we're being truthful.
- Which is an
evolutionary thing.
So as an evolutionist I
could go with that lie.
- Yeah.
- But, but when it comes
to the truth and certainly
important elements of truth,
then you should never
be a consequentialist.
So you should never negate
biological realities
in the pursuit of
social justice.
I could both walk and
chew at the same time.
I could be for social
justice and the truth is
that I am for trans rights.
- Of course.
- I take great flack
for supporting trans rights
in the Middle East which is,
which they have a much
more difficult reality
than trans rights on
Oberland College right?
But I don't support the,
because of my support
for trans rights doesn't
mean that a 270-pound guy
who is six foot four who
decides that he is now a woman
can compete with biological
women who are half his size
and to say otherwise would
make me a transphobe.
So I could chew and
walk at the same time.
- Yeah, well it seems that
a lot of people can't,
can't do that these days.
What do you think it will take
truly to get us past this?
That seems to be the next
step of this conversation.
Okay we talked about it for
awhile, we understand it.
Now the masses see a problem.
But what is the thing,
beyond just the courage part.
I mean what, what
would be a societal way
to actually put some of
this stuff behind us?
- So certainly having sort of
a cataclysmic, you know savior
Trump come along.
But the reality
is Trump is only,
is gonna be out either in a
few months or in a few years.
So you can't just rely on Trump
because he ended critical
race theory, then the problem,
that idea pathogen is
gonna go away forever.
But you certainly need some.
- But Gad I thought,
I think he's never, I thought
he's never gonna step down
and he's gonna be President
to 2064 or something.
I could've, I thought.
- Exactly, exactly.
So certainly having
someone who was able
to come from the
outside and redress
many of these things is great.
But I truly think it's a
long game you know, war.
There has to be involvement.
So I'll give you an example.
My, one of my children,
her science teacher
has a BLM sign as an avatar.
So I could do one of two
things at that point.
I could say well forget it.
Or I could write politely.
Right, without
being too bomb acid,
without engaging all
sorts of Gad-isms.
You know cutting satire.
I could write to her
politely and say,
you know is it appropriate
for a science teacher
who is educating my
young child to espouse
a particular position?
What if we don't agree
with this position right?
So I can, at that point
I have a bifurcation.
I can either get involved
or not get involved.
That has to happen 300
million times a day
in every interaction
and every exchange.
If that happens,
the wall of bullshit
will collapse quickly.
If it doesn't, it will be a
long drawn-out, needless war.
So this is why I implore
people, get engaged.
Your voice matters.
It's not only up
for, to Dave Rubin
to change the course of culture.
Each of you is important.
- So obviously I
have to ask you,
did you ask the
teacher to do anything?
I know we all pick our
spots, we pick our fights.
What'd you do?
- I haven't, I haven't
yet because you know,
my wife was worried
that I might engage
in some sort of
cutting positions
that might not be
modulated well enough
and that might cause sort
of a retribution with that.
So in that particular
case I've yet to do it
but I can tell you
that my daughter
has often come up
to me and said,
daddy, the BLM is still up.
So I think she's kind of almost
egging me to get involved.
And in a sense look.
By my children being around me
and seeing the
positions that I take,
that's one of the ways
by which I fight right?
So if I do that and you
do that with your children
and he does that with his.
By the way the cretins are
always trying to introduce
the idea pathogens
ever so earlier.
So it starts with
the universities,
then we go to the high schools,
then we go to the elementaries
because the best
time to reach a mind
to make it as
malleable as you can
is when it doesn't have
yet the cognitive defenses
to protect itself against
the idea pathogens.
By the way, she's the
one who made the joke.
Yesterday she was eating
something during Kippur
and she said well
don't worry daddy,
I self identify as, as right?
So this little child
who has heard my satire
was able to construct
that satirical moment.
- I was told a story
by a friend of mine
who has a five-year-old that in,
you know, the school year
just started and that one of,
the parents sent around a note
to the other
parents in the class
that the boy, biological boy,
he's a boy at home but wants
to be a girl at school.
So they want everyone
to refer to him
as whatever the girl name is,
the female name at school.
But then he goes home
and he's a boy again.
And again, without, this
is not mocking trans people
or anything like that.
But it's sort of the
way it all spills over
so that everyone else
has to behave the way
you want them to behave.
But also could this
possibly have come
from the five-year-old?
I wanna be a girl at
school but a boy at home.
Like, doesn't really
sound like that.
- No and listen, I
have my younger son
who's younger than my daughter.
Once came up to me and I
did a sad truth clip on it
on my channel where
he saw something,
I can't remember
the exact details
but it was something like,
the future is female,
male toxicity, toxic masculinity
and he was sitting
with me watching
and he kind of looked at me
and I don't remember
his exact words
but he said something like,
"Daddy, are boys really bad?"
It was really with the
innocence of a young child
and imagine that
you are inculcating
to half the world's
population known as boys
this kind of
pathological stage right?
You're pathologizing
masculinity, it's grotesque.
We could, we could be feminists
in the truest sense of the term.
In the Christina Hoff
Sommers sense of the word,
without being pathologizing
half of the world called boys.
- Yeah I know Jordan
wrote a blurb,
Jordan Peterson wrote
a blurb for the book.
That's really what
he was hitting on
more than anything else right?
I mean he was trying to,
well I can't say more
than anything else.
But in conjunction with
many other big things.
That you can't say
to all these boys,
you're inherently evil
and now he's been gone
for a year and a half and I
think a lot of people are lost
without that.
- Yeah and I gotta say,
since he is a common friend.
When I wrote to Jordan it was,
to get from him the
endorsement for the book.
It was literally at
the worst possible time
when he was going
through all his stuff
and he writes right
back to me and says,
you are literally the first
person I'm responding to,
you know, since
opening my laptop.
This is the kind of
friendship that matters.
Right, Jordan and I can
disagree on some things.
We disagree on Jung,
we disagree on.
But even if we disagree
on points A and B,
when it comes to going
into the trenches together,
you wanna have guys
who have your back
and at his lowest moment,
he was willing to take time.
So love the guy.
- Gad, are you telling
me that academic people
could have different beliefs,
come to different conclusions
and not try to get
each other fired
or kicked out of the
university or out
of all the social clubs?
- Incredible isn't it?
Incredible isn't it, who knew?
- It's just bizarre.
What else can the
average person do?
I mean that to me is where
this all comes together,
the average guy.
I mean because what it
always comes down to also
is the person going,
forget the tenured part
that you talked
about at whatever
and that certain people's
makeup isn't to be combative.
But just the person
who's going you know,
I'm just at whatever my job is.
You know I'm a decent
hardworking person.
I've got kids, I've got all
these other responsibilities
and for me to do
that little jump.
Even though I think most
people agree with you.
Most people heard what you said
and they go well, 300 million
people all did at once,
we really could change
something overnight.
But in their own life,
they just can't do it.
Are there any other tricks?
This is a question
I get all the time.
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean so in chapter
eight, the last chapter
I do have a set
of prescriptions.
The chapter's called
Call To Action,
so I'll give you a few.
One of them does address
the fact that you said,
oh some of them
are not combative.
The reality is, you
can't have your values
and principles
murdered and raped
without ever being combative.
If I'm walking down
the street with my wife
and three guys come
to gang rape her,
I can't say sorry, sorry
sweetie, I'm not combative.
So good luck right?
So I have to, and then one
of the prescriptions I have
is activate your
inner honey badger.
Now the reason why again I
use this animal comparison
because honey badgers
don't give an F right?
Honey badgers, you can
have a, a pride of lions.
Six lions, you can go on
YouTube and see those clips.
You can have six
lions approach a,
a honey badger is the size
Emma may she rest in piece.
A small, a small dog
and the response will be
so ferocious that
the six, six lions
will look at each other
and go what the hell,
I don't want part of this right?
So you can't really
fight in a war.
In this case a war of ideas
without ever
triggering your ire.
Without ever being indignant.
So you can't be passive,
you can't be castrated.
So unfortunately you have to
once in awhile be combative.
So activate your
inner honey badger.
I also have another one where
I say be the penalty kicker.
In soccer there is, if
there's a foul inside the box,
the goalie box,
there's a penalty kick.
From 12 yards away,
someone has to step up
and take a penalty kick.
Now it's a very
harrowing experience
because the goalie expects
to not be able to save it.
If the guy who
misses it misses it,
he's an asshole, he's a loser.
So really the one who
steps up to take it
is the one who says
I want this coach,
put the responsibility on me.
It's the one that has
the fortitude to do it.
Well you have to do that.
You can't, you know
you can't subcontract
and diffuse the
responsibility onto others.
There is no magic recipe,
you all have to get engaged,
that's the bottom line.
- So as a behavioral scientist,
have you ever met anyone who
did some of these things,
found their honey badger,
took the penalty kick,
the rest of it.
Anyone who did some of these
things and regretted it?
Longterm.
- Oh that's a good question.
No, I thought you
were gonna ask me
do you know anybody other than
myself who is a honey badger?
- No I've got my
shortlist of people here.
No but really, 'cause that's
one of the things I find.
I always say to people you know
it's, it will, there's pain.
Your family members
are gonna turn on you,
friends are gonna turn on you.
Coworkers, blah blah blah.
But I still to this
day, I personally
have never met anyone
that regrets it.
- No and I tell you, I think,
I can answer it for myself.
The reason why I never
regret it is because
at the end of the day
I have a very exacting
code of personal conduct.
So when I go to bed at night
and I put my head on the pillow,
I have to feel,
before I go to sleep,
otherwise I'll have insomnia.
That I've done all that I could.
However big or however small
to contribute to the battle.
If I walked away
tepidly from a place
where I could've intervened,
then I will feel like a fraud.
So in order to
forestall insomnia
and feelings of being a fraud,
I have to always be
the honey badger.
I have to always walk
into the proverbial,
you know ideological fight
and I think that once you
are driven by that passion,
then you never regret it.
Because you're living
a true life right?
I'm very authentic,
whether you like me or not,
I am who I am and if you
don't like it, too bad,
if you like it great.
And therefore I
feel good in myself
and I think most of the people
who rise to that challenge,
probably have a similar makeup
so they don't regret it.
- Yeah I wanna test
you with something
that was sort of off-book
topic but kind of there too.
That as we deal with COVID
and watching you know,
the spread of misinformation
and we're supposed
to wear masks,
we're not supposed
to wear masks.
Lockdowns work, they don't work.
You know, flatten the curve
becomes eight months of
don't go out of your house,
et cetera et cetera.
That feels very relevant
to the book actually
in terms of the way we
take in information,
the way our fear centers
operate and everything else.
What do you make about
what's going on generally
with all of it?
- You know it's so interesting
because I was just having
this conversation with my wife
who went for a walk
and I said you know,
usually I can very
quickly get a sense of
what is the information
that I need to know
so that I can form an opinion
and if I don't know
something, I have a humility.
I'll say you know,
I don't know enough
about legalization of
marijuana to take a position
and I feel dumbfounded
at this point
regarding this COVID
'cause I simply can't,
I'm getting, you know
it's not like I'm an idiot
who can't synthesize
information.
But precisely for
what you're saying,
I'm getting so
many mixed signals.
Even if I try to
read the literature
that I can't make sense
of what's up, what's down.
I mean I've had on my own show,
you know virus experts
who have said that
it is a complete overreaction.
That the lockdown, and these
are very serious virologists.
These are not like
quacks and so on.
So I really, the best
answer I can give you
is I truly don't know whether
this is one big conspiracy.
I don't mean conspiracy in that
COVID is not real and so on.
But that whether our reaction
to it has been grossly,
you know over the top
or not, I don't know.
- So as a behavioral
scientist though,
like one of the things
that I think all the time
is when I go.
You know I'm in SoCal, it's
warm and sunny every day.
Everyone looks good and is
in tank tops and you know,
basically healthy and you
go into the supermarket
and we wear masks.
Now I've noticed, people
don't look at each other also.
'Cause when you can't see
part of someone's face,
you sort of don't even
see another human.
And what I'm worried
about is that the ways
it will change our behavior.
I think that could
be your next book
is the way that this, the
way that the lockdowns
and masks changed our behavior.
Or just how quickly
we just accept things.
- Yeah.
- Which I suppose
has an evolutionary answer.
- Yeah I mean dear leader
says jump, you say how high.
I mean I, earlier when I
was chatting with my wife
I gave an analogy.
So if you look at you
know, a healthy environment
for a child to grow up in,
they should have
consistent parenting.
In other words, if
a child runs to you
when you come home at night
and because he wants to hug you
and you slap him because
you've had a bad day,
that's not a very healthy.
Right, 'cause then the
child can't predict
statistical regularities.
They don't know when
you're gonna spank them
versus praise them right?
So you have to have
consistent parenting.
Well then I analogize this
with the COVID reality
that we're facing.
Most of us are sort
of these children
who don't know when the
next edict is gonna come.
So that I can try to
start making sense of
what are the
statistical regularities
that I should look for in
order to create a trajectory?
Should I get married next year
or will it be on lockdown?
Should I go on vacation next
year or will it be on lock?
And I think it is one gross,
sort of misprinting experiment
that we are facing
and the consequences
are gonna be quite
nefarious I think.
- Well I can tell you
for sure where I live
in California the parents
ain't doing a great job
if Gavin Newsom is my dad
and Eric Garcetti is my mom.
Although you got your own
problems with Trudeau so we can,
we can have a different
therapy session
about our parents.
- But how come you haven't,
to continue with the
parenting analogy,
how come you haven't escaped
and ran away from home to Texas
or Nashville or
wherever the rest
of the good folks
are running to?
- Because I wanna fight.
I believe it's worth saving
and I think there's a chance
and maybe I'm right,
maybe I'm wrong
but I said to David
before you know, we moved
and, but we stayed in L.A. and
I said, if I can't live here.
I mean if someone like
me, it would be like you
being like if someone like
me can't live in Canada,
I can't live in this country.
Like the thing has gotten so
crazy, I can't live in Canada.
Well for a certain period
of time and I suppose,
I know this is a, it's an awful
analogy in a certain level.
But there were, there
were many stories.
Anne Frank's neighbor you know.
They, they kept saying you
should get out of Germany,
get out of Germany and she said
but we have a nice house
and it'll blow away.
And I'm not comparing
this to that
as much as it, some people
I think you're either wired
to fight a little bit longer
and some people aren't.
But who knows, maybe I'll
be moving in with Shapiro
in Nashville not too long.
- So you're already
a honey badger.
You've already activated
your inner honey badger.
- Honey badger, from one
honey badger to another.
All right Gad, we're
gonna link to the book
The Parasitic Mind right
below and you know,
we could talk forever so next
time in person my friend.
- You're the best sir.
Thank you so much for
having me, cheers.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about academia
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our academia playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlists.
They're all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.